sans empêcher ou fermé massivement les
activités du quotidien c'est parce que
nous avons deux vaccins les français ne
s'y sont pas trompés 53 millions d'entre
eux ont reçu au moins une dose le rythme
des primo vaccination a augmenté
récemment à la faveur notamment du débat
sur le passé vaccinale comme nous
l'avions déjà connu lorsque le débat sur
le passé ni terre était arrivé dans
l'agenda public à l'agenda public qui
avait entraîné la vaccination de plus de
12 millions de français supplémentaires
il faut saluer parce que le choix de la
science et du savoir c'est toujours le
bon choix il faut appeler tous les
français éligibles à les faire également
le rappel puisque le rappelle la
troisième dose pour celles et ceux qui
le nécessitent on fait les protections
bien plus forte encore contre les
risques de formes graves et
d'hospitalisations
oui je n'esquive pas nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts et nous devons
aller vers celles et ceux qui un peu
éloigné de la formation où notre système
de santé n'ont pas encore un accès au
vaccin nous devons aussi inciter celles
et ceux qui ne sont pas hostiles au
vaccin mais qui tantôt par
l'indifférence totaux tantôt par
nonchalance ne franchissent pas le pas
et puis il ya également celles et ceux
que nous aurons du mal à convaincre par
des mesures pédagogiques et par des
entretiens avec les médecins les
pharmaciens les infirmiers c'étaient
ceux qui pensent encore qu'on leur veut
du mal en leur proposant un vaccin qui
protège une partie d'entre eux cela sera
peut-être convaincre par la mise en
place du pass vaccinale pour eux les
registres rationnelle ont été mobilisés
en vain mais nous ne devons pas relâcher
nos efforts toutefois à court terme de
nouvelles mesures de freinage ont été
décidés je pense notamment au nombre
minimal de trois jours de télétravail
par semaine pour les poches tout cela
est possible au port du masque à
l'intérieur dès l'âge de 6 ans à la mise
en place de jauge pour les spectacles
culturels et sportifs nous avons
également décidé d'adapter les règles en
matière d'isolement et de quarantaine
afin de tenir compte de l'évolution
extrêmement rapide de la diffusion du
variant omicron des données virologiques
disponibles et du souci de maintenir la
vie socio économique du pays et la
pérennité des services publics sur la
base d'un avis rendu par le haut conseil
de santé publique le 31 décembre dernier
ces règles ont été harmonisés simplifiés
depuis lundi dernier enfin et c'est
précisément l'objet du présent projet de
loi nous souhaitons renforcer plusieurs
outils de gestion de la crise sanitaire
déjà prévues par la loi en premier lieu
le projet propose ainsi un
approfondissement des mesures de
protection avec cette transformation du
pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale afin
de renforcer les incitations à la
vaccination mais aussi je le redis de
réduire les risques de contamination une
étude française d'ailleurs a été publiée
que j'ai pris connaissance ce matin de
qualité qui montre qu'à une réduction de
la charge virale expiré par les
personnes contaminées par le cos vide
lorsqu'elles sont totalement vacciner
après la promulgation de la loi il sera
donc nécessaire de présenter un
justificatif vaccinale pour accéder aux
activités de loisirs au restaurant haut
débit de boissons aux foires séminaires
salons professionnels et transport
interrégionaux je le redis pour les
établissements santé sociaux et
médico-sociaux et sauf en cas d'urgence
le texte maintient le dispositif actuel
du pass sanitaires en cas d'urgence rien
ne s'applique évidemment vous savez pour
les patients accueillis pour les soins
programmés les accompagnateurs et les
visiteurs le projet doit provost proroge
également jusqu'au 31 mars 2022 l'état
d'urgence sanitaire à la réunion et en
martinique parce que la situation
sanitaire préoccupante justifie de
maintien de mesures de freinage renforcé
le texte adopté hier en commission ont
fait de même en guadeloupe saint
barthélemy saint martin guyane et à
mayotte par ailleurs le projet de loi
renforce encore les mesures qui
permettent de lutter contre la fraude
nous savons combien la pratique de la
fraude au pass sanitaire peut être
dangereuse pour les personnes qui s'en
rendre responsable toute personne
habilitée à demander la présentation
d'un pass pour a ainsi exigé la
présentation d'un document afin de
vérifier la concordance d'identité nous
aurons sans doute le débat nous l'avons
eue à l'assemblée nationale la
concordance identité n'est pas un
contrôle d'identité les sanctions
encourues par un gestionnaire
d'établissements pour manquement à
l'obligation de contrôle du pass seront
également renforcés ainsi qu'en cas de
fraude nous proposons également un point
important que les services préfectoraux
puisse connaître des données strictement
nécessaire à leurs missions de contrôle
des mesures de quarantaine et isolement
afin de vérifier que chaque personne
concernée a bien réalisé le test négatif
qui conditionne la levée de la mesure
dont il a fait l'objet c'est en effet la
condition indispensable d'une maîtrise
des chaînes de transmission enfin je
précise qu'il s'agit là d'un sujet bien
distincts de ceux relatifs à la crise
sanitaire nous vous proposons
d'entériner ce qui avait déjà été
entérinés d'ailleurs dans le plfss 2022
mais retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel au titre de cavaliers
sociale le renforcement de
l'intervention du juge des libertés et
de la détention dans le cas de régime de
contention et d'isolement en psychiatrie
le texte a été modifié par l'assemblée
nationale sur plusieurs points relevant
de la police sanitaire pour s'assurer du
respect par les employeurs de leur
obligation de prévention notamment en
matière de télétravail mais aussi pour
adopter pour adapter l'application du
pass vaccinale aux mineurs ou encore
pour faciliter l'engagement dans un
parcours vaccinale des personnes ayant
commis une fraude au pass sanitaires il
a également été complété par plusieurs
mesures visant à soutenir le système de
santé tels que la prolongation de la
garantie de financement des
établissements de santé et de
dispositifs d'indemnisation de la perte
d'activité des médecins les adaptations
règles de cumul emploi retraite pour les
professionnels de santé et la
prolongation de la prise en charge à
100% de la téléconsultation
en fin de texte qui vous a été soumis
réactive des mesures adoptées lors des
phases précédentes de la gestion de
crises sanitaires en matière de règles
de réunions des assemblées générales de
copropriétaires de constitution des
jurys d'assises ou encore d'organisation
des concours de la fonction publique ce
texte a été significativement modifié à
l'initiative de votre commission des
lois et de votre commission des affaires
sociales parmi les principales
modifications adoptées en commission je
relève en particulier que vous avez
souhaité définir des seuils de
déclenchement du pass vaccinale au
niveau national ou à défaut au niveau
local en fixant directement dans la loi
un nombre d'hospitalisations cible nous
aurons l'occasion d'en débattre vous
avez également proposé d'exclure
l'application du pass vaccinale pour les
mineurs là où l'assemblée nationale
l'avait maintenue à la
différence sortant du pass vaccinale les
seuls 12 15 ans pour toutes les
activités extra et périscolaire de
nature culturelle sportive par exemple
vous avez souhaité exclure la
possibilité d'appliquer le pass
vaccinale ou le past and i ter aux
centres commerciaux et aux grands
magasins vous avez supprimé le
dispositif inséré à l'assemblée à
l'initiative du gouvernement pour
faciliter l'engagement dans un parcours
vaccinale des personnes ayant commis une
fraude au pas ce qu'on appelait le droit
au remords ou à la repentance peu
importe la terminologie vous avait
écarté le dispositif de sanctions adopté
par les députés pour assurer le respect
par les employeurs récalcitrants de
l'heure actions de prévention en matière
de santé et vous avez restreint la prise
en charge à 100% des téléconsultations
aux actes s'inscrivant dans un parcours
de soins coordonnés nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir sur ces
modifications lors de la discussion des
articles du projet de loi les
propositions d'amendements présentés par
le gouvernement ne puisse pas l'ensemble
des sujets de discussions mais nous
avons souhaité nous concentrer sur les
points les plus saillants à ce stade
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
l'aurez compris le texte qui vous est
présenté ne bouleverse pas à l'économie
générale de la gestion d'épidémie il
vient renforcer et enrichir les outils
mobilisés pour maîtriser au mieux
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire il
demeure tout entier guidé par la
recherche de cet équilibre difficile
avec le souci premier de protéger des
français tout en assurant la continuité
de la vie de la nation est en nous
évitant collectivement d'avoir à prendre
des mesures plus contraignantes je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
je vais donner la parole
rapporteur de la commission des lois
monsieur philippe bas
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame et monsieur les
présidents de commissions et mes chers
collègues
tout a été fait pour que ce débat soit
perturbé par des polémiques
vous me permettrez de ne pas y prendre
part
à ceux qui sont certains d'avoir
toujours raison
dans leurs raisons d'ailleurs
successives
je poserai
simplement mes propres doutes et les
quelques convictions qui ont pu s'en
détacher vous m'excuserez aussi de ne
pas recourir un vocabulaire
fracassant pour me faire entendre
j'ai toujours pensé que venant de leurs
représentants les français
ressentent la vulgarité
comme une humiliation et non comme une
marque de proximité
mais je ne prétends pas exercer la
police du langage
la vitesse de propagation du virus est
sans précédent
paradoxalement ce texte n'a pourtant pas
pour objet de répondre à l'urgence
sanitaire
pour la quasi totalité des français
le pass sanitaire est déjà un pass
vaccinale
nous disposons d'ailleurs d'un arsenal
législatif
considérable que le gouvernement ne
souhaite mobiliser qu'avec parcimonie
il s'est d'ailleurs raté avec lenteur
depuis l'annoncé faite par le premier
ministre le 17 décembre dernier quand il
avait fait quand il avait fallu mettre
fin à la crise des gilets jaunes en
décembre 2018 la fai avait été bouclé
quand trois jours et nous y avions
coopérer à la veille de noël de même le
parlement avait su adopter en trois
jours la loi du 23 mars 2020 créant le
régime de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
nous y avions aussi coopéré depuis lors
le sénat a constamment assumer ses
responsabilités et s'étant engagés dans
la lutte contre l'épidémie en conjuguant
exigences sanitaires
respect des libertés et
contrôle parlementaire il a toujours
accordé aux autorités sanitaires les
pouvoirs nécessaires
en posant ses propres conditions c'est
dire combien serait inacceptable toute
mise en cause de notre esprit de
responsabilité
dans un contexte d'instrumentalisation
politique de la lutte contre le coc vide
par l'exécutif
quand on est confronté à 100
200 ou 300 milles contamination par jour
sinon plus une réponse qui reposerait
essentiellement sur une forme
d'incitation vaccinal sous contrainte
entrant en vigueur à partir de la mi
janvier mais ne produisant ses premiers
effets qu'à partir de la fin du mois de
vrille et il faudra du temps pour que
les nouveaux convertis à la vaccination
soient pleinement protégés
n'étaient en aucun cas à la mesure du
problème
d'ici là au rythme actuel
c'est sans doute une dizaine de millions
de français très majoritairement
vaccinés qui auront été contaminées avec
des retombées certaine sur le système de
soins qui sont aujourd'hui très probable
il est vrai que sans que l'on puisse
encore en déterminer la mesure exacte le
variant au micron qui évince désormais
le variant delta semble beaucoup moins
offensif et ouvre l'espoir d'une sortie
du tunnel épidémique je veux y croire
mais ici et maintenant nous sommes
confrontés à une urgence sanitaire à
laquelle le pass vaccinale aussi utile
qu'il puisse être ne répond pas le
désordre à l'école dans le travail et
surtout à l'hôpital auquel le
gouvernement n'a pas préparé le pays ne
sera pas réparé par des imprécations
contre les non vaccinés qu'il faut
convaincre au lieu de les montrer du
doigt au risque de les braquer
je suis
fermement partisans de la vaccination
depuis le début elle a déjà sauvé de
nombreuses vies humaines et elle en sort
encore tous les jours
ces effets indésirables doivent être
rapportées aux risques épidémiques
auxquels nous sommes confrontés que le
vaccin réduit sans pouvoir l'éliminer
il y à un large consensus médical en
faveur du vaccin si des voix
scientifiques discordantes existent
auquel il convient bien sûr de prêter
attention il n'y a pas de choix plus
raisonnable que de s'appuyer avec
humilité sur ce consensus d'autant que
les résultats positifs du vaccin pour la
santé publique sont tangibles il atténue
fortement le risque d'être malade ou de
déclarer une forme grave de la maladie
ce sont des fêtes
l'un des enjeux est donc essentiel est
donc bien aujourd'hui encore de
convaincre les hésitants de changer
d'idée sur la vaccination d'abord pour
eux mêmes et pour leurs familles ensuite
pour l'ensemble de la collectivité
nationale mais comment faire pouvons
nous imaginer réussir à convaincre ceux
de nos compatriotes qui craignent de
vaccins plus que le coc vide en les
outrages ans ou même simplement en
essayant de les circonvenir
vaccinez vous vous pourrez aller au
restaurant et au cinéma
pardonnez moi monsieur le ministre mais
cela révèle une piètre opinion des
français que de leur maître en main un
tel marché on ne peut à la fois faire
appel à la responsabilité de chacun de
nos concitoyens il est traité de manière
aussi infantilisante en situant l'ordre
de leurs priorités de manière aussi
dégradantes beaucoup de nos compatriotes
qui refusent le vaccin le font par
conviction
nous sommes en désaccord avec eux sans
doute car ils se mettent en danger leur
imprudence aggrave les tensions sur
notre système de soins fragilisée mais
comment faire évoluer leurs convictions
sans leur montrer d'abord un peu de
respect n'est pas juste de les accuser
d'être à l'origine de la flambée de
l'épidémie puisque les trois quarts des
personnes actuellement contaminées sont
vaccinés on ne peut davantage leur
reprocher de saturer l'hôpital car les
malades du covan hospitalisé en soins
critiques sont pour près de la moitié
des personnes vaccinées si l'hôpital est
aujourd'hui sous tension c'est dû à la
fatigue collective d'une institution
éprouvé par le cos vide s'est liée aussi
aux contaminations au sein même des
équipes de soins mais ce n'est pas sans
rapport non plus avec une politique
hospitalière qui n'a commencé à
s'intéresser à l'usure dans notre
système de soins qu'avec la crise
sanitaire
de ce point de vue
les non vaccinés ont bon dos en
l'absence d'obligation vaccinale les
personnes non vaccinées sont donc dans
leurs droits même si leur comportement
soulève un réel problème de santé
publique par conséquent le seul argument
médical possible en faveur du pass
vaccinale c'est l'argument de la
protection et non celui de la punition
nos compatriotes non vaccinés sont plus
exposées que les autres à une forme
grave de co vide surtout quand ils
appartiennent à des catégories
médicalement vulnérables ils ont donc un
intérêt majeur à se faire vacciner mais
et s'il tarde à le faire ils doivent se
protéger plus encore que nos autres
compatriotes télétravail s'ils sont
actifs masque tels gestes barrières
tests réguliers et bien sûr éviter de
fréquenter les lieux qui les expose le
plus aux contaminations à commencer par
ceux où l'on mange et où l'on boit parce
qu'il n'est pas possible d'y porter un
masque comme à cette tribune nous sénat
avant déjà admis à trois reprises
l'utilité d'une contraintes sanitaires
pour l'accès à des lieux qui expose aux
contaminations et accepter de l'adapter
à l'évolution du contexte épidémique en
mai en juillet et en octobre à chaque
fois nous avons posé nos conditions et
fait en sorte que l'exigence de contrôle
de la représentation nationale soit
respectée et nous avons refusé les
chèques en blanc en imposant leur tour
devant le parlement si les paramètres du
pass sanitaire devait évoluer nous y
voilà de nouveau et ce débat législatif
que vous avez monsieur le ministre à
toute force voulu éviter en octobre
lorsque nous avions fixé l'échéance de
février vous avez décidé de l'ouvrir en
janvier sans enthousiasme je vais donc
proposer au sénat d'admettre ce
durcissement du pass pour des motifs de
protection sanitaire que j'ai énoncé
mais en assortissant notre accord de 4
conditions destinées à préserver les
libertés et la responsabilité de chacun
le maintien du pass ne sera pas laissée
à la discrétion du gouvernement actuel
et de ceux qui le suivront jusqu'au 31
juillet le pass s'éteindra de lui-même
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
les critères que nous aurons posé seront
réunis les entreprises accueillant du
public ne sont ne seront pas contraintes
d'opérer des vérifications d'identité
mais ce seront en revanche protégés par
la loi quand elles demanderont un
document avec photographie pour vérifier
qu'il correspond bien aux passes
l'inspecteur du travail ne pourra
substituer son appréciation à celle de
l'employeur sur la nature des postes
télétravail à bhl ni infligé à
l'entreprise de sanction pénale en
fonction de cette appréciation
les règles applicables aux mineurs de
plus de 12 ans pour leurs sorties
scolaires et extrascolaires seront
simplifiées et unifiée pas de passes
vaccinale en dessous de 18 ans
si ces conditions sont respectées je
vous demanderais mes chers collègues
d'approuver les propositions de vos
commissions nous adresserons aussi une
double mise en garde au gouvernement
face à la déferlante au micron il doit
sortir d'une posture attentiste
susceptible d'amplifier la crise est de
désorganiser la société l'école
l'hôpital et l'économie et face à
l'émotion causée par les propos
blessants tenus par le président de la
république la semaine dernière il doit
réparer au plus vite les torts faits à
la cause de la vaccination en renouer le
fil du dialogue avec nos concitoyens non
vaccinées dans ce domaine comme dans
d'autres il vaut mieux convaincre que
stigmatiser le président de la
république le sait d'ailleurs par
expérience qui déclarait il ya moins
d'un mois qu'il y a des mots qui peuvent
blesser sur le site que ce n'est jamais
bon et même inacceptable que je leur
site le respect fait partie de la vie
politique et qu'on ne fait rien bouger
si on n'est pas pétri d'un respect
infini pour chacun on ne saurait mieux
dire
merci monsieur leur bon coeur
[Applaudissements]
je venais la parole au rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des affaires
sociales madame chantal de seine
[Applaudissements]
parole match et recollait
merci monsieur le président mais c'est
le président monsieur ministre madame
monsieur les présidents des commissions
mes chers collègues les effets du
variant delta est depuis décembre de la
rapide propagation du variant micron
conduisent notre pays affronte et une
double vague d'épidémie qu face à celle
ci est alors que la vaccination est
aujourd'hui notre principal est plus
efficace outil de lutte contre le virus
le gouvernement nous invite à
transformer le pass sanitaire en passe
vaccinale l'objectif affiché est double
restreindre l'accès des non vaccinés au
lieu identifié comme propice à une
contamination et les inciter par là même
fortement à se faire vacciner il s'agit
donc d'abord de protéger les non
vaccinés eux-mêmes mais aussi de
répondre à l'impératif fondamental
qu'est la préservation de la santé des
français dans leur ensemble
or alors que notre système de soins est
sous tension et nos soignants épuisé
garantira la santé d'une concitoyens
c'est bien aussi prévenir des
hospitalisations évitables grâce à la
vaccination et donc réduire les
déprogrammations et la saturation de nos
hôpitaux et partant limiter les pertes
de chance si nous regrettons que le
gouvernement n'assume pas clairement une
obligation vaccinale de fait notre
commission a choisi de soutenir
l'adoption de ce nouvel outil concernant
les articles dont la commission des
affaires sociales s'est vu déléguer au
fond l'examen 4 prolonge des dispositifs
dans le champ de la santé
l'article 1er bis vise à prolonger la
prise en charge intégrale par
l'assurance maladie des
téléconsultations
l'article promis quater prolonge le
dispositif des deux médecins libéraux
des établissements de santé
l'article 1er sexuelle ouvre la
possibilité d'une nouvelle garantie de
financement des établissements de santé
pour le premier semestre
1022 l'article le premier cas caisse à
étant une nouvelle fois la dérogation
aux règles de cumul emploi retraite pour
les soignants notre commission des
affaires sociales n'a pas été sans
réserve à l'égard des nouvelles
dérogations proposé à la hâte dix jours
après la promulgation de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
aurait légitimement pu les porter aussi
même si elle a validé l'essentiel de ces
dispositions elle a souhaité encadrer la
nouvelle exonération du ticket
modérateur
alors que le retour au droit commun doit
pouvoir se faire pour les
téléconsultations deux autres articles
issus d'un amendement du gouvernement
adopté en séance concerne le droit du
travail l'article 1er bis a institué un
régime de sanctions administratives
applicables aux employeurs qui ne
respecteraient pas les principes de
prévention des risques d'exposition de
leurs salariés à la coved 19 le recours
au télétravail est en visée par le
gouvernement les employeurs qui sont
déjà soumis à l'obligation d'assurer la
santé et la sécurité de leurs salariés
sous peine de sanctions pénales se sont
très largement mobilisés depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire la commission a
rejeté cette nouvelle logique
coercitives qui n'apparaît ni utiles ni
souhaitables et qui donnerait une trop
large marge de manoeuvre à l'inspection
du travail par ailleurs l'article
premiers obtiennent prévoit un nouveau
report des visites médicales qui doivent
être assurées par les services de santé
au travail dans le cadre du suivi de
l'état de santé des travailleurs
l'accumulation des reports pouvant être
préjudiciables
la commission on a limité la portée aux
visites et examens qui n'ont pas encore
été reporté en application de
précédentes mesures en outre afin de
prévenir le risque d'engorgement des
services de santé au travail à l'issue
de la crise nous avons à vous renvoyer à
2023 l'entrée en vigueur de la nouvelle
visite de mi-carrière prévu par la loi
santé au travail
janvier enfin l'article 3 relatif à
l'isolement-- à la contention dans le
cadre de soins psychiatriques sans
consentement qui vient complet combler
une autre dipl censure constitutionnelle
du fait de la légèreté du gouvernement
lors du dernier plfss et malgré les
avertissements répétés de notre
commission des affaires sociales
l'abrogation 1er janvier laisse
aujourd'hui un vide juridique au
détriment de toute sécurité juridique
mais surtout de la sécurité des patients
et de la préservation de leurs droits
une saisine systématique du juge est
désormais prévue après un certain délai
qui peut ordonné la main levée de la
mesure où autorisé son maintien la
commission a adopté cet article mais a
souhaité notamment préserver la liste
actuelle des personnes informées en cas
de telles mesures au bénéfice de ses
observations la commission des affaires
sociales a donné un avis favorable à
l'adoption de ce projet de loi a ainsi
modifié je vous remercie merci madame le
rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues nous allons passer
la discussion de la motion qui tend à
opposer la question préalable
aux collègues loïc hervé a déposé une
motion distribuée sous le numéro 35
tendant à opposer la question préalable
au texte en discussion je vais lui
donner la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le sénat
que j'aime c'est le sénat qui à la suite
du projet de loi safari a proposé la
création de la commission nationale
informatique et libertés le sénat que
j'aime c'est le sénat qui lie à 40 ans
le 35 en 1981 a aboli la peine de mort
le sénat que j'aime c'est le sénat qui a
interrompu le funeste projet de
déchéance de nationalité
jalouse de son pouvoir législatif
la haute assemblée a dans son histoire
toujours été au rendez-vous la
préservation des libertés publiques y
compris quand elle a dû brider les îles
exécutif et ses excès nous en sommes au
12e textes législatifs en 22 mois la
caisse à outil n'est jamais assez
complète et à chaque fois le
gouvernement vient demander au parlement
de la compléter
ce faisant nous avons pris l'escalier
sans retour de la limitation des
libertés publiques et nous devons nous
poser maintenant la question de la
marche arrière
je m'oppose à ce texte pour deux raisons
le pass vaccinale tout d'abord au micron
déferle sur la france et les personnes
testées positives se comptent par
centaines de milliers chaque jour y
compris et massivement parmi les
vaccinés
je sais de quoi je parle on devrait
s'interroger légitimement sur l'utilité
des mesures privatives de liberté
actuellement africa dans notre pays pour
cela il nous faut des éléments objectifs
et chiffrés dont nous ne disposons pas
monsieur le ministre ensuite il ya les
contrôles d'identité le texte propose de
donner aux responsables des
établissements la possibilité de
vérifier massivement l'identité de leurs
clients mais quelle mouche a piqué le
gouvernement pour avoir une idée
pareille qu'elle effondrement de la
pensée et du débat politique nous a
conduits là quand les résignés 10 on n'a
pas le choix les penseurs ne vois pas le
problème quant au visionnaire il affirme
que ce n'est la pas la loi qui limite
les libertés mais le virus je
m'interroge où est la gauche des droits
de l'homme où est la droite des libertés
ou sur les syndicalistes les
universitaires les intellectuels ils
sont si rares ce qui rappelle de la
liberté mes chers collègues je vous
propose de dire un non ferme et
définitif à cette très mauvaise idée du
pass vaccinale qui nous conduit tout
droit au contrôle social généralisé
alors je voudrais conclure avec
tocqueville monsieur le rapporteur
cet état se veut si bienveillants envers
ses citoyens qu'il entend se substituer
à eux dans l'organisation de leur propre
vie ira-t-il jusqu'à les empêcher de
vivre pour mieux les protéger de même le
plus grand soin d'un bon gouvernement
devait être d'habitués peu à peu les
peuples à se passer de lui
merci
[Applaudissements]
y at il un orateur contre la motion
sur leurs peurs quel est l'avis de la
commission ap adorateurs contre la
motion bien sûr inventeur
merci monsieur le président c'est
presque un débat philosophique notre
très estimé collègue hervé viennent de
lancer est-ce que par principe il
devrait être interdit à la république
tellement attaché l'état de droit fondé
sur la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de restreindre ou de
limiter temporairement des libertés pour
faire face à une crise majeure cette
question a été posée à nombreuses
reprises dans notre histoire et pas
simplement du fait de la crise
épidémique elle a été posée lors de des
événements comme on disait à l'époque
d'algérie elle a été posée plus
récemment lors des émeutes des banlieues
en 2005
elle a été posée encore lors de la
récente vague terroriste et elle est
posée aussi dans le cadre de la lutte
contre l'épidémie
voyez vous dans notre pays patrie des
droits de l'homme les libertés sont
sacrés mais aucune liberté n'est pas un
absolu sur le fondement de la liberté
c'est l'article 6 d'intégration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui dit
que la liberté consiste à pouvoir faire
tout ce qui ne nuit pas à autrui
on n'est jamais allé plus loin dans la
définition de la liberté que dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui a
valeur constitutionnelle dans notre pays
et qui montre que la liberté se rapporte
toujours à des limites qu'il appartient
au législateur de poser ce que nous
faisons nous sénat depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire comme nous l'avons
fait dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
terrorisme ces dernières années c'est de
mesurer
avec la recherche du meilleur équilibre
possible les restrictions pour qu'elles
soient strictement nécessaires à la
poursuite d'une feinte supérieur en
l'occurrence
l'éradication de l'épidémie de covin 19
c'est pourquoi chers collègues tout en
vous ayant écouté comme toujours avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et d'attention je ne
peux pas partager votre point de vue
philosophique
dans la défense de cette motion et je
dois vous dire que je préfère de
beaucoup que notre sénat plutôt que de
refuser le débat
rentrer dans celui ci pour jouer son
rôle qui va consister précisément à
déplacer le point d'équilibré trouvé à
l'assemblée nationale pour faire en
sorte de limiter les restrictions à nos
libertés
pour qu' il n'y ait aucune restriction
qu'ils ne soient strictement nécessaire
à l'objectif de santé publique à juste
titre le président le gouvernement nous
demande de poursuivre avec lui dans la
discussion de ce texte est pourquoi
monsieur le président la commission est
défavorable à cette motion tout en
remerciant tout en remerciant
l'auteur de la motion
de l'initiative qu'il a prise d'ouvrir
ce débat tout à fait captivant
merci monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
le gouvernement défavorable yat il des
explications de vote
oui sur la roche
merci monsieur le président si je
comprends parfaitement d'exaspération de
notre collègue
devant ce énième texte dont on sait
qu'il n'apportera pas de solution réelle
à la situation aiguë de l'épidémie que
nous connaissons notre groupe ne peut
s'associer à cette motion oui le texte
présenté par le gouvernement n'est
qu'une obligation vaccinale déguisés et
ceux initialement pour tous les plus de
12 ans
si nous combattons l'ensemble des
restrictions de liberté conclut dans ce
projet de loi
notre assemblée s'honore à s'emparer
d'un sujet si grave alors que le
gouvernement a trop souvent considéré
notre short comme une étape dont il se
serait bien passé la conférence des
présidents a obtenu que ce débat se
déroule dans de bonnes conditions dans
une temporalité plus à même de faire
émerger des positions argumenté et des
contre propositions réalistes oui ce
texte est dangereux nous vous rejoignons
chers collègues sur beaucoup de points
et notre opposition nous engage à en
discuter il est essentiel que le
gouvernement souffre d' écouter nos
positions et nos propositions aussi si
nous comprenons les éléments qui
soutiennent cette motion nous pensons
que la tenue d'un débat est essentiel
nécessaire est plus que justifiée par
l'ampleur des conséquences de cet état
d'urgence sans fin sur notre pays
merci d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote
je n'en vois point
je vais consulter le
sénat sur la motion temps d'en poser la
question prix adam je vous rappelle tout
simplement et chers collègues que si
cette mesure venait à être adoptée ça
entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
ceux qui sont favorables à cette
motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable le manifeste en levant la main
avis contraire
attention
il n'est pas adopté
nous allons maintenant aborder la suite
de notre discussion générale et je vais
donner la parole à notre collègue alain
richard pour le groupe du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes qui est
indépendant et pour six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame et monsieur le président
mes chers collègues une nous faut donc
poursuivre l'adaptation de nos règles ou
mouvements de la pandémie en gardant
comme point cardinal la sécurité des
français dont nous sommes coresponsables
avec l'exécutif et ce en laissant vivre
la société
la circulation du virus est beaucoup
plus intense
se maintiennent les formes graves un
haut niveau puisque si la proportion de
létalité du virus du variant omicron est
beaucoup plus faible la circulation se
multiplier par un facteur au moins 5 et
donc nous sommes toujours exposé à une
surcharge du système de santé à un
nombre excessif de décès
notons l'impact déjà très favorable de
la vaccination qui réduit de plus de 90
% le risque de formes graves pour ceux
qui en ont bénéficié
nous recevons de nombreux messages
critique fréquemment impérieux tous nous
demandait de refuser cette nouvelle
étape du pass vaccinale
il est légitime que les citoyens nos
mandants nous interpelle et nous devons
garder le respect pour leur sensibilité
pour leur argumentation
mais il ya une limite qui est celle des
injures et plus encore des menaces dont
les auteurs doivent être rappelés au
sens commun et si nécessaire à la loi
et puis notre impératif centrale pour
nous législateurs c'est d'écouter la
science tous les cercles et institutions
légitimes offrant les garanties de
rigueur et de probité dans l'analyse de
cette maladie nous le disent à part des
cas de contre-indication rare et bien
délimitées il est confirmé que les
vaccins approuvés évite à 80 voire 90 %
les formes graves sans effets
indésirables constatés après plus d'un
milliard de personnes vaccinées depuis
un an
nous devons donc
accepté la règle plus strictes qui nous
est proposé dans le projet du pass
vaccinale est donc refusé l'accès des
principaux lieux publics aux personnes
non vaccinées dans leur propre
protection comme ça bien été dit par le
rapporteur et pour freiner la
circulation
je serai observées aux collègues qui ont
réclamé avec de bons arguments le
passage à l'obligation vaccinale que
s'il voulait que cette mesure s'applique
il faudrait évidemment qu'elle est aussi
des conditions d'application qui comme
par hasard se révèlerait être
rigoureusement les mêmes que celles qui
sont réclamés pour le pass vaccinale ce
qui me laisse bien augurer de leur vote
sur ce texte
nous allons nous pencher sur quelques
cas de restriction et de dérogation
principalement celles concernant les
enfants et adolescents pour lesquels
nous préférerons pour notre part la
règle commune dès 16 ans plutôt qu'une
dispense trop générale allant jusqu'à 18
ans
le sujet de la fraude mérite notre
vigilance
si les enquêtes menées par la police
établissent d'ores et déjà
180 milles fausse vaccination faut pas
se vaccine heures dax hinault enfin
sanitaires pour l'instant les
constatations de la société française
d'anesthésié et de réanimation
font apparaître et c'est un tout autre
chiffre environ 5%
de personnes détenant un faux-pas ce
vaccinale dans celles qui sont
hospitalisés rendez vous compte mes
chers collègues que si ce sondage qui
est appliqué sur plus d'un tiers des
services de réanimation en france et par
les scientifiques si ce pourcentage
baisse vérifier cela signifierait qu'en
réalité le nombre de faux passe en
circulation utilisés par leurs
détenteurs serait plutôt de l'ordre de 2
millions donc le risque les risques
induits par la fraude doivent être pris
au sérieux et c'est pour cela que la
vérification de la conformité de
l'identité
du titulaire du pass doit être fait elle
n'est pas plus intrusive que pour
encaisser un chèque ou pour acheter un
paquet de cigarettes
quand on a un abord un abord juvénile
et le risque d'être pris en faute
réduira significativement leur cour
ouvre aux faux parce qu'ils sont fait un
vrai danger donc il nous semble qu'il
faut maintenir cette disposition prévue
dans le texte
nous préférons aussi
maintenir la faculté pour l'inspection
du travail de prononcer des mondes être
des amendes administratives
en cas de réelle prise de risque pour le
personnel soulignons que d'une part la
proposition qui a été faite par la
commission de retirer cette faculté ne
touche pas aux sanctions pénales qui
sont pourtant plutôt plus grave et plus
pénalisante de l'entreprise que les
sanctions administratives
et rappelons-nous bien sûr que ces
sanctions administratives sont je dirais
parmi les incultes et normal statutaire
de l'inspection du travail dans tous les
domaines qui touchent la sécurité au
travail
cette crise
encore encore en cours d'accentuation
pour j'espère une période limitée mais
une fois de plus en lumière le courage
des soignants et des autres
professionnels des services au public
enseignants personnels de sécurité
travailleurs de l'espace public et j'en
oublie ils sont un rappel vivant à notre
obligation d'être vigilants et efficace
dans notre mission de législateurs
merci
de donner maintenant la parole au
président claude malhuret pour le groupe
les indépendants
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
mes chers collègues contrairement à ce
que prétend depuis des mois les
trafiquants de fake news les résistants
des boulevards les has not been de la
chanson française et les sakharov de la
dictature sanitaires nous avons
aujourd'hui trois certitudes
premièrement le vaccin empêche l'immense
majorité des formes graves deuxièmement
la probabilité d'un séjour en
réanimation est dix fois supérieur chez
les non vaccinés troisièmement les
services d'urgence sont remplies par la
petite minorité qui refusent la
vaccination
la conclusion est d'une simplicité
biblique il faut vacciner
pour vacciner le plus de monde possible
le plus vite possible
92% des français l'ont compris par les
anti vaccins depuis un an il nous tanne
avec leur convaincre plutôt que
contraindre nous disent de faire de la
pédagogie de ne pas stigmatiser qui
stigmatisent tous les autres il faudra
bientôt vacciner en cachette et raser
les murs pour ne pas les déranger
eh bien nous ne l'ont pas raser les murs
nous allons répondre et d'abord aux
politiciens aux abois qui essaient de se
refaire la cerise on philosophe de
comptoir qui confondent liberté et
irresponsabilité aux agités du télé
bocal qui crient à la démocratie bafouée
l'est filippo asselineau le pen dupont
aignan ou melançon ce pacte
germano-soviétique de la désinformation
ont été
ont été successivement pour la
chloroquine contre le vaccin contrôle
pas sanitaires et maintenant contre le
pass vaccinale avec une infaillibilité
absolue dans l'ameublement ces amoureux
des dictatures il faut quand même qu'ils
soient gonflés pour accuser le
gouvernement et le parlement de prendre
des mesures liberticides
s'il avait été au pouvoir la vaccination
aurait perdu des mois et les mort aurait
été bien plus nombreux comme chez leurs
amis ball sauna roulante ivax ou poutine
et son vaccin est inopérant réclamant
agrandi réclamé à grands cris par
mélenchon et ont même les russes ne
veulent pas les français n'auraient eu
droit
les français n'auraient eu droit qu'aux
remède bidon d'un gourou rocambolesque
validé par la twitter school of man et
signer la facebook university ces
stakhanovistes de l'erreur et du cynisme
sont contre le pass vaccinale pas pour
préserver la santé de nos concitoyens
mais pour récupérer les voix des
extrémistes
quoi que vous fassiez monsieur le
ministre
pour eux vous ferez mal je vous suggère
une idée pour vacciner les 5 millions
qui manquent à l'appel interdisez le
vaccin ils exigeront que tout le monde
se leva s'injecter
maintenant ça suffit à 300 mille cas par
jour il est temps de répondre il aussi
plus que temps de faire front la
démocratie ce n'est pas s'agenouiller
devant une minorité inconsciente qui
peuplent aujourd'hui les services
d'urgence qui fait pleurer de rage et
l'épuisement les soignants voyant leur
lit rempli le patient qui n'aurait
jamais dû s'y trouver et qui en savent
tous les autres la démocratie ça ne
consiste pas à écouter des rebelles de
supermarchés sauter comme des cabris
avec leur pancarte en criant liberté
des quinze ans de ma vie comme médecin
dans les guerres ou les épidémies j'ai
tiré une leçon simple ce sont les virus
qui bafouent les libertés pas les
vaccins et si l'on ne prend pas les
mesures qui s'imposent c'est l'épidémie
seul qui en décident et toujours de la
façon la plus violente et la plus létale
il faut donc parce qu'il n'ya pas de
liberté absolue comme le disait philippe
bas tout à l'heure trouver l'équilibré
entre des libertés contradictoires et
prendre les bonnes décisions même si
elles ne plaisent pas à tous c'est ce
que vous nous proposez aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre
et c'est ce que nous allons faire avec
vous oui le pass vaccinale est une façon
de poursay la vaccination et pour tout
dire l'idéal serait la vaccination
obligatoire comme il en existe onze
autres sans que personne ne lui hurle à
la tyrannie
vous ne proposez pas
attendez la fin attendez la fin vous ne
proposez pas parce que vous craignez que
les boutefeux ne finisse par déchirer un
pays exténué et parce qu en démocratie
il n'y a pas de moyen infaillible de
l'imposer et vous avez sans doute raison
alors va pour le pass vaccinale les
offusqués professionnels diront que vous
créer deux catégories de français alors
que ce sont eux qui se place en marge et
nous met en danger ils diront que
voulait stigmatiser
alors que depuis un an il traite et
vacciné de moutons les soignants de
collabo qu'ils saccagent les permanences
des élus et les menaces de mort mais
nous allons poursuivre ensemble
calmement la lutte contre l'épidémie
malgré eux et avec l'immense majorité
des français car en dépit des campagnes
incessantes sur les réseaux sociaux
antisociaux les français ont montré une
remarquable compréhension une
remarquable patience et une remarquable
responsabilités malgré les intox la
france est dans le peloton de tête des
pays les plus vacciner les réseaux ont
même eu une vertu après deux ans de
bobards nos concitoyens ont fini devant
l'énormité des fake news par se faire
une solide opinion sur ceux qui les
diffusent et je préfère ne pas répéter
ici les épithètes dont il les gratifie
quant aux discussions dans les repas de
famille où se trouvait un anti vague
pendant les fêtes elles ont vacciné
définitivement des millions de français
contre les absurdités et se vexer vabre
par sens il est d'une grande efficacité
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président tout d'abord
je voudrais remercier les présidents de
groupe qui offre qui ont accepté que je
prenne la parole maintenant avant les
orateurs de la coupe monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2020
nous avions du mal à croire à une
seconde vague mais nous voilà début 2022
en pleine pandémie et d'autres peuples
fait face avec courage mais aussi
lassitude et résignation
oui il faut lutter frontalement contre
l'épidémie oui il faut vacciner et
protéger la population mais deux ans
après le début de l'épidémie vous ne
pouvez plus dissimuler la réalité c'est
l'insuffisance de moyens de la santé
publique qui pousse à la mise en oeuvre
de politiques autoritaires de
contraintes qui porte lourdement
atteinte aux libertés publiques
c'est l'hôpital public la médecine de
ville mais aussi l'assurance maladie qui
sont défaillants non pas du fait d'un
personnel qui est exemplaire de
dévouement et de courage mais du fait
des choix libéraux de ces dernières
années maintenu malgré la prob émis par
emmanuel macron et votre gouvernement
alors nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
votre stratégie de rideau de fumée vous
masquez des mesures par des mesures
coercitives comme le pass annie terre
puis le pass vaccinale pas départ l'état
d'urgence permanent l'incurie d'un
système qui a ravalé la santé au rang de
marchandises je le souligne d'emblée si
le pasa mystère si le plan sanitaire a
boosté la vaccination force est de
constater qu'il n'a pas ralenti la
propagation du virus pour preuve trois
cent mille personnes sont testés
positifs par jour
quelle est donc l'utilité de ces sésames
ce rideau de fumée c'est aussi
l'aggravation verbal du président de la
république contre des millions de
personnes non vaccinées dont beaucoup ne
le sont pas par choix mais par
éloignement fait l'ess ou
incompréhension quelle est cette france
où l'on sonde les gens pour savoir si
les soins doit toujours être accordée à
ceux qui refusent le vaccin oui vous
fabriquez des parias pour détourner le
débat et nous dénonçons ce jeu dangereux
nous proposerons par voie d'amendement
et cela en préalable à la discussion du
texte que l'entrée en vigueur du pass
vaccinale soit conditionnée à la remise
par le gouvernement au parlement d'un
rapport sur l'impact et sur le recul de
la propagation de l'épidémie de kobe 19
car si comme je les dis se passe a pu
être utile faute de politique de santé
publique efficace pour inciter à la
vaccination l'on peut aujourd'hui se
demander ce qui légitime sa prolongation
et son durcissement
instrument auquel s'ajoute celui d'un
traçage numérique étatique banalisée qui
tend lui même à s'amplifier se durcir
comme le propose article 2 du texte en
étendant l'accent l'accès aux données
personnelles médicales aux services
préfectoraux il est temps de mettre fin
ce système de passes inutiles sur le
plan sanitaire et dangereuse sur le plan
des libertés publiques bien d'autres
solutions sont possibles des solutions
d'ordre véritablement sanitaires et non
sécuritaire comme l'accentuation des
gestes barrières et des moyens de lutter
contre la prorogation le déploiement des
purificateurs d'air la distribution des
masques ffp2 l'effectivité du recours au
télétravail lorsque cela est possible ou
encore l'organisation de roulement dans
les entreprises dans les établissements
scolaires par exemple plus globalement
il s'agirait comme nous avons nous avons
de celle de le soutenir d'investir
davantage dans la médecine de ville et
la médecine scolaire et de réarmer
l'hôpital public en bref des mesures
pratiques qui répondent à la crise
sanitaire en souhaitant protéger nos
concitoyens et non les punir enfin il ne
s'agit pas d'une épidémie mais bien
d'une pandémie
la question est donc mondiale est la
seule réponse efficace sera de cet ordre
c'est pourquoi je le redis encore il est
plus urgent que jamais de lever les
brevets sur les vaccins pour éviter
l'émergence de nouveaux variants seuls
50 % de la population mondiale et
vaccins idée un plan de vaccination
massive dans le monde doit être déployée
plutôt que de taper sur le point du
poing sur la table en insultant toute
une partie de nos concitoyens
emmanuel macron aurait tout intérêt à
profiter de la présidence française de
l'union européenne pour convoquer un
sommet international et engagé un bras
de fer salutaire autour de la levée des
brevets sur les vaccins et d'un
gigantesque effort des aides au
développement en france nous avons
débloqué des centaines de milliards pour
l'économie combien pour la santé
combien pour la solidarité
internationale
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
vous en conviendrez nous sommes prêts à
être force de proposition et à débattre
des mesures propres à gérer la crise
sanitaire mais pour l'heure malgré les
tentatives du rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour atténuer
certaines mesures nous nous opposons à
cette énième projet de loi sécuritaire
et d'intimidation d'un tranquillisation
de nos concitoyens et de
déresponsabilisation
déresponsabilisation de nos dirigeants
emmanuel macron le 12 mars 2020 avait
annoncé extraire la santé de la loi du
marché or il est aujourd'hui payés à
notre patte dans son quotidien par des
décisions solitaire le refus de
s'attaquer aux dogmes libéraux qui
étouffe l'hôpital la santé et notre pays
nous refusons cette impasse sanitaires
mais aussi démocratique merci madame non
donner la parole maintenant à notre
collègue guy benarroch pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires
la parole mon cher collègue
c'est le président messieurs les
rapporteurs cher collègue monsieur le
ministre je sers au parlement comme je l
ai été pour tous les autres textes qui
portent sur l'urgence sanitaire on
associe énormément le parlement la
démocratie cote avez vous déclaré le 22
décembre dans une célèbre matinale si je
suis désolé de n'avoir pas remarqué
votre présence toutes les fois
précédentes
je suis ravi de vous voir ce jour ce
texte n'aura pas d'effets sur les vagues
en cours sur la désorganisation de la
société sur le drame de l'école m
l'ouverte coûte que coûte au lieu d'être
sécurisée coûte que coûte ce texte ne
répond pas à une nouvelle urgence
sanitaire ce texte n'est pas destiné à
freiner la propagation du virus ce n'est
pas son objet
les écoles sont en souffrance votre
doctrine de matières des écoles ouvertes
se doit d'évoluer vers le maintien dans
de bonnes conditions
ffp2 pour les professeurs détecteur de
co2 quand même si vous affirmer qu'on
peut à errer sans les détecteurs c'est
plus simple de respecter les limitations
de vitesse quand on est un conteur
agir maintenant dans une phase explosive
de contamination est au mieux peu
efficace pourtant tous les signes
étaient là dès fin novembre
dès la montée du delta et avec les
premières informations sur au micro rien
n'a été fait à ce moment là malgré
l'avis du conseil scientifique
mais comme souvent depuis février
dernier le gouvernement cherche à
réfléchir seul jusqu'au dernier moment
les conseils de défense ou secret se
multiplient et les avis comme le dernier
du hcsp sur les ffp2 ne sont accessibles
que selon votre calendrier la droite
sénatoriale roumègue mais votre toujours
en essayant d'encadrer périmètre est dur
et nous sommes donc en état d'urgence
perpétuelle sécuritaires sanitaires et
quoi d'autre ensuite vous focaliser sur
des objectifs dérivés une lutte contre
leur confinement supérieur à la lutte
contre l'épidémie un désir de sauver
noël plus grand que celui de sauver
notre système hospitalier
derrière vos choix d' équilibre il y as
au mieux un attentisme optimiste au pire
ça critiquable calculs politiciens
revenons au pacini terre puis vaccinale
à cette obligation vaccinale déguisés et
pourtant non obligatoire je vous
rappelle que d'autres groupes
écologistes a alerté dès le début est
régulièrement sur le risque d'une
généralisation trop importante de se
passe à la fois dans le temps mais aussi
dans son périmètre dans les activités où
les lieux qu'ils toucheraient ou même
les maladies ou cause qui entraînerait
sa mise en oeuvre le présent renforce
nos alertes et nous laisse augurer d'une
société de contrôle permanent camouflé
par des état d'urgence successifs et
récurrent doc nous voici devant un texte
qui prévoit trois types de passes
sanitaire vaccinale vaccinale plus ça
doit être ça le pragmatisme dont vous
vous réclamez sans cesse texte qui
prévoyait en plus l'obligation du pass
vaccinale des douze ans une obligation
vaccinale déguisée des douze ans
heureusement retiré par d'autres
commissions sous l'égide de ce
rapporteur que je salue cette vision
séparatistes de la société triés par les
passes successifs nous la rejetons nous
y sommes totalement opposés se passe
vaccinale ouvre en quelque sorte l'accès
à la possibilité de transmission et de
propagation sans autre moyen compterait
alternatifs comme les tests pcr ou les
masques ffp2 je rajoute que cela laisse
à penser que pour travailler se déplacer
sortir dans des lieux publics vivre en
quelque sorte nous devons bientôt en
permanence et définitivement pour des
années nous faire vacciner plusieurs
fois par an mais se fasse se passe
pourquoi insister maintenant quelles
nouvelles urgences et connurent décembre
il nous est apparu que son efficacité
était surtout liée à l'incitation à la
vaccination qu'il a suscités et tant
mieux mais comme j'avais déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire ici sans
efficacité en tant que tel c'est à dire
les effets de sorts pouvoir de limiter
l'accès des personnes non vaccinées à
certains lieux d'ozil et peu étudié et
encore moins quantifier sur le moyen
terme c'est pourtant ce pouvoir là
qu'ils devraient être jugés aujourd'hui
je le redis ne passe en tant que
solution unique un effet pervers c'est
une illusion de croire une faute de
laisser croire en sa protection avec une
circulation active du virus et une
immunité déclinante cette illusion
s'accompagnant du relâchement flagrant
des gestes barrière est un danger plus
grand que vous ne prenez pas
suffisamment en considération
qui plus est une partie du public
prioritaire des toujours prévient
vacciner les plus fragiles les plus
précaires les plus pauvres les plus
éloignée de l'épicentre de notre vie
sociale ne le sent pas suffisamment et
ce ne sont pas des anti vaccins le pass
vaccinale aura-t-il un effet protecteur
sur cette population ou encore les
campagnes d'aller vers votre but étant
la protection de la population
particulièrement la plus fragile c'est
là que doivent se concentrer vos efforts
à ce titre je vous demande aussi de nous
dire aujourd'hui la vérité de vos
attentions sur le besoin et les
modalités du quatrième dose et son
implication sur le pass vaccinale que
nous allons voter aujourd'hui peut-être
la vaccination est un outil majeur est
indispensable mais pas le seul pour
toutes ces raisons de vision et
d'installation d'une société de contrôle
et liberticide de mode de doom de
gouvernance de gestion devrais-je dire
verticale solidaire et fluctue en
prenant un peu chacun de nous à tour de
rôle comme irresponsable et utilisant
des outils de propagande critiquable de
succession de lois d'urgence sanitaire
de reprendre plus dit un nouvel état
d'urgence ni un objectif de freiner la
contamination nos groupes écologistes
solidarité territoire votera contre ce
texte qu'il tentera de rendre
acceptables par de nouveaux abonnements
merci de donner la parole à notre
collègue stéphane le rudulier pour le
groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la même monsieur le président
de la commission mesdames et messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
notre haute assemblée est une nouvelle
fois réunis afin d'examiner un texte
traitant de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
c'est le douzième texte de cette nature
depuis près de deux ans alors l'idée
même de ce nouvel arsenal de mesures
serait de protéger davantage la
population sans devoir recourir à des
mesures de restriction généralisée dans
un contexte où la vaccination est le
meilleur outil pour permettre de lutter
durablement contre le virus
mais néanmoins et cela a été dit par le
rapporteur ce texte n'est pas une
réponse à l'urgence sanitaire ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas son objet il ne va pas
réduire le rythme de circulation de ce
variant au micron à court terme
par ailleurs sa mesure phare le pass
vaccinale qui se substituerait au pass
sanitaire n'est pas sans poser quelques
questions à nombre de nos concitoyens
il y a tout d'abord les anti pacs
arriverons-nous à
convaincre ces anti vaccins sans les
offenses et sans les injurier ceux qui
sont radicalement opposées au vaccin
seront ils plus convaincu par le pass
vaccinale qui ne l'ont été par le pass
sanitaire c'est toute la question de ces
prochaines semaines et puis il y à un
certain nombre de france de français
vaccinés eux qui sont totalement
désemparé perdu face à ce phénomène
d'accumulation de mesures prises par le
gouvernement et sur les contraintes qui
s'ajoutent les unes aux autres mesures
qui viennent parfois se contredire d'une
semaine sur l'autre je pense
tout particulièrement aux enseignants
aux parents d'élèves aux dirigeants
associatifs aux milieux culturels
comme je peux les comprendre car
monsieur le ministre votre péché
originel
c'est votre méthode de communication qui
peut paraître parfois totalement
incongrue par rapport à la nature des
annonces faites je vais prendre un seul
exemple quand une conférence de presse
du premier ministre et de vous-même le
27 décembre dernier
débouche sur l'interdiction de manger un
sandwich dans le train de consommer du
pop corn au cinéma de boire son café
debout ou encore l' annonce du retour
des fameuse jauge pour les événements
culturels ou sportifs qui ne sont pas
proportionnés à la taille des enceintes
j'ai envie de vous dire tout ça pour ça
cela pourrait sembler anecdotique si ça
n'entravait pas la bonne gestion de la
crise sanitaire sanitaire en jetant
notamment le doute sur l'efficacité de
l'action publique et sur la nécessité de
poursuivre l'effort vaccinale alors il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire et à
redire sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement mais
faudrait-il pour autant transformer le
vote sur ce projet de loin en référendum
sur votre gestion de crise la réponse
est non je ne le pense pas ce serait
totalement irresponsable
au regard de la situation sanitaire le
sénat a d'ailleurs toujours fait preuve
de responsabilité a toujours été dans
une logique constructive et rationnelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
rapporteur a proposé de faire évoluer le
texte selon quatre grandes orientations
que je tiens rapidement rappelés en
premier lieu s'agissant du pass
vaccinale nous proposons mise en
extinction automatique sans pouvoir
discrétionnaire
donner au gouvernement dès lors que la
situation épidémique s'améliore celle ci
étant mesurée par des critères cumulé
qu'est le nouveau le niveau d'eau spitz
alisation sur le plan national une
circulation faible du virus et un taux
de vaccination très élevé sur le plan
local cette disposition permet ainsi de
garde ir de garantir une
proportionnalité entre les limitations
des libertés individuelles et la réponse
à l'urgence sanitaire j'en viens au
deuxième point la question épineuse de
l'extension du pass vaccinale aux
mineurs le dispositif particulièrement
illisible conçu voté à l'assemblée
nationale doit être remplacée par une
règle claire qui nous semble préférable
seul le pass sanitaire sera exigé
jusqu'à 18 ans pour les sorties
scolaires ou encore les loisirs la
restauration ou les déplacements inter
régionaux s'agissant maintenant du
renforcement des dispositifs de contrôle
et de sanction nous avons une conviction
forte ce n'est pas la vocation des
restaurateurs des hôteliers des
cafetiers en somme de toutes personnes
chargées des contrôles au sein des
établissements recevant du public de
jouer le rôle d'officier de police
judiciaire
en contrôlant les cartes d'identité ou
en identifiant des faux la commission a
donc strictement limitées cette
disposition mais c'est un point qui sans
nul doute fera débat au sein de notre
hémicycle
dans quelques instants enfin et pour
conclure nous avons supprimé
l'institution d'un régime de sanctions
administratives pour les entreprises ne
respectant pas certaines préconisations
sanitaires tels que le télétravail ce
dispositif coercitif kiehl sd pouvoir
d'appréciation tellement large sur
l'organisation du travail au sein
d'entreprises par l'inspection du
travail risquer de donner naissance à de
nombreux contentieux pour au final ne
concernait qu'un nombre très restreint
d'entreprises voilà mes chers collègues
le texte qui vient de la commission
propose au sénat de conserver la
position d'équilibré et de cohérence qui
a été la sienne durant la crise
afin de garantir la conciliation des
objectifs de lutte contre les plis mini
de préservation des libertés publiques
et de garanties du contrôle
parlementaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle les sénateurs du groupe et
l'air voteront donc dans leur majorité
le texte des commissions espérons que la
majorité des députés entendre à la
sagesse du sénat dans le cadre de la
commission mixte paritaire et permettra
un projet de loi équilibré je vous
remercie merci retenait
la parole et
un autre collègue philippe bonnecarrère
un livre que
de l'union centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
le parlement n'est pas le greffier de
l'exécutif
le sénat et le lieu du débat dans débat
apaisé et nadir surprenante le débat sur
le post vaccinale a fait l'objet d'une
sorte de dramaturgie dramaturgie à
l'assemblée dramaturgie peut-être aussi
par les innombrables mail que vous avez
reçus les uns et les autres je vous
proposerai de la relativiser le pass
vaccinale et le pass sanitaire moi ce
vous le savez tous la possibilité
d'accéder au restaurant ou de prendre le
train en se faisant tester chaque fois
que l'on voudrait yale
quel est le nombre de nos concitoyens
qui se faisait ou se font tester très
régulièrement à leurs frais depuis le 15
septembre pour se livrer à leurs loisirs
il est probablement très faible monsieur
le ministre vous avez été interrogée
lors de votre audition vous nous avez
pas donné d'indication mais nous pensons
effectivement très faible ce qui veut
dire que de quoi le pass vaccinale est
le nom de cette idée que chaque crise
doit avoir
une loi en réponse c'est ce qui explique
le fait que vous soyez saisi pour la
douzième fois monsieur le ministre est
l'orateur précédent l'ont souligné c'est
finalement l'idée que le gouvernement
doit prouver qu'il agit et protège et
dans ce cas précis il propose le pass
vaccinale au lieu du pass sanitaire nous
sommes en réalité sur un changement
lexical si je devais résumer tout cela
pour cela pour le groupe centriste la
priorité va à la santé publique
la pression de cofidis menace est
considérable et chacun peut la mesurer
autour de soi au-delà des statistiques
qui nous ont été rappelés autour de nous
et au delà des personnes atteintes vous
avez pu mesurer la réalité déco vide
blanc où la réalité des formes dur que
telle ou telle de vos amis aux relations
a pu subir sans être forcément
hospitalisé le virus est effectivement
très lourds très durs dans ses
conséquences et même avec un variant
moins virulent le risque pour nos
concitoyens et pour le système
hospitalier est majeur la réponse est
connue de tous la vaccination
le pass sanitaires ou vaccinale est
certes une mauvaise solution pour les
libertés il n'y a pas de bonne solution
sur ces sujets mais force est de
constater que nous n'avons pas trouvé de
solution alternative meilleur pour
favoriser la couverture vaccinale du
pays
c'est ce qui explique que très
majoritairement avec la liberté de vote
qui lui est traditionnel notre groupe
approuvera le pass vaccinale avec des
conditions et des sérieux bémol ce qui
me donne l'occasion de remercier
philippe bas notre à porter pour la
qualité et la pertinence de son travail
la première condition est probablement
la principale est celle de
l'atterrissage de la sortie il est
facile vous le savez chers collègues de
déclarer un état d'urgence de se doter
d'un pass sanitaires ou vaccinale il est
beaucoup plus difficile de s'en extraire
de s'en sortir et sans comparer
totalement les situations vous avez vu
après 2015 la difficulté de sortir des
mesures antiterroristes dans la réalité
nous ne sommes pas sortis puisque nous
les avons les pérenniser
c'est dire que la clause de caducité est
fondamentale le pass unitaire doit être
et rester exceptionnelles il doit avoir
une fin notre à porter a fait une
proposition combinant nombre de patients
hospitalisés de taxi nation et taux de
circulation se réserve d'ajustements sur
ses écrits terre ou sur la durée notre
groupe est très favorable à une clause
de caducité ou d'extinction automatique
du passé ni terre au delà la seule
référence à la date du 31 g pour nous
les deux choses sont liées si je devais
les résumés oui au pass vaccinale oui à
la clause de caducité
deuxième condition au deuxième bémol là
situation des jeunes permettant aux
jeunes de 12 à 18 ans de vivre leur
jeunesse notre société a été dur avec la
jeunesse de france depuis deux ans nous
partageons l'objectif de la commission
des lois de donner plus de souplesse et
de revenir au système antérieur du pass
vaccinale à l'égard des jeunes c'est à
dire les permettre de poursuivre leurs
activités avec un test négatif
troisième bémol la vérification
d'identité le vient d'être évoquée par
l'orateur précédent nous sommes très
réservés nous sommes ouverts à la
discussion
le rapporteur a proposé qu'il n'y ait
pas de vérification de la carte
d'identité et la possibilité de
présenter d'autres documents portant une
photographie nous ne voyons pas très
bien à quoi correspondrait cette
situation une pensons plus généralement
qu'il y aura très peu de situations dans
lesquelles par exemple restaurateurs
estimera qu'il ya une raison sérieuse
d'aller au delà de la production du pass
sanitaire nous sommes en résumé ouvert
les discussions mais objectivement très
réservé pas très loin de la position
de rejet kt proposé par le groupe
socialiste mais la discussion nous
permettra d'aller un peu plus loin
quatrième condition quatrième bémol la
sanction des entreprises en matière de
télétravail les entreprises nous
semble-t-il ont été impeccables dans
cette crise l ont bien compris qu'il
était essentiel de protéger leurs
salariés nul n'avait intérêt à ce qu'il
y est un critère dans son entreprise au
risque d'entraîner son arrêt d'activité
nous ne voyons pas de raison de renoncer
à cette situation de confiance et de
rentrer dans une logique de sanction
reste pour moi évoquer à notre sujet
c'est n'est pas ce qui est dans le texte
c'est ce qui n'est pas dans le texte
nous luttons contre une pandémie vie au
sens giral ni ajoutant pas la pandémie
démocratique ou présidentielle vous le
savez tous l'élection présidentielle est
la clef de la voûte de nos institutions
nous sortons de dispositions légales
ayant été adoptées pour faciliter le
vote aux municipales pour faciliter le
vote au départemental et aux régionales
comment pourrait-il expliquer être
expliquer qu'il n'y aurait pas de
facilité donnée pour le vote à
l'occasion d'élections présidentielles
et a fortiori pour les conditions de
campagne il ya même une forme d'humour
dans le texte puisque vous avez un 1er
septembre vous irez vérifier qui donne
au gouvernement les moyens de faciliter
la tenue des assemblées générales de
copropriétaires
vous motorisera penser que l'élection
présidentielle est a fortiori un sujet
ayant vocation à être traités or nous
savons que le sujet organique nous
autres groupes à propose à préparer une
ppl organique portant sur deux
procurations dédoubler les bureaux de
vote et élargir la campagne à la
télévision nous la proposerons à tous
les groupes de cette assemblée mais
avant nous souhaitons avoir la position
du gouvernement sur cette question et je
termine en évitant de rajouter ma petite
phrase à celles qui ont déjà pu être
prononcée à l'égard des déclarations des
plus hauts responsables
de l'état je ne crois pas qu'il faille
rabaisser les gens je ne crois pas que
quiconque ni à gagner à niveler par le
bas la société mais le vrai sujet c'est
que cette obsession cette idée qu'il
faut élever la voix pour être audible va
de pair avec l'accélération du rythme
électorale et avec le quinquennat et la
vraie cause de cette outrance que nous
constatons les uns et les autres autour
de nous c'est que l'outrance et
profondément la conséquence de la
malédiction du quinquennat
merci mon cher collègue
le donner la parole à notre collègue
maryse carrère pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
la parole mme chow collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues après les tumultes que
ce texte a pu connaître à la semaine
dernière que les perturbations viennent
de l'exécutif ou de parlementaires le
sénat peut donc enfin se pencher sur la
question du pass vaccinale et je sais
que nous prendrons la mesure de
l'importance et de la solennité du sujet
de sorte que notre débat sera apaisée et
construit pour le dire sans détour le
groupe rdse dans sa grande majorité est
favorable à tout dispositif d'incitation
à la vaccination voire pour certains
d'entre nous à l'obligation vaccinale
nous voyons dans nos départements
combien les hôpitaux sont débordés
épuisés et nous sommes également peiné
de voir les familles endeuillées alors
que certains patients s'ils avaient été
vaccinés aurait pu guérir de cette
maladie car nous connaissons de mieux en
mieux le virus son mode de
fonctionnement et ses effets et plus les
mois passent plus nous avons de recul
sur l'efficacité du vaccin par exemple
dans les hautes-pyrénées sur huit
patients en réanimation
sept sont non vaccinés aujourd'hui il
faut donc trouver le moyen le plus
opérants pour achever cette campagne
vaccinale faudrait-il durcir
l'incitation comme le propose le
gouvernement à travers le nouveau pass
faudrait-il penser un nouveau mécanisme
d'obligation comme peuvent le suggérer
cette certaine bien entendu le texte
idéal n'existe pas chacun trouvera
toujours à redire du dispositif choisi
mais ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
l'immobilisme certains membres du rdse
ont pu très tôt se prononcer en faveur
de l'obligation vaccinale au point
qu'aujourd'hui avec ce nouveau pass nous
nous interrogeons sur l'opportunité de
maintenir un faux semblant de liberté de
choix
c'est sans doute trop tard mais un autre
dispositif aurait pu être imaginé en
amont afin d'épargner par exemple à nos
restaurateurs hainaut caph étiez toutes
ces contraintes quotidiennes que nous
pourrions d'ailleurs encore alourdir en
leur ouvrant la possibilité d vérifier
l'identité des détenteurs de pass
il demeure que le chemin du passé ni
terre avait été choisi et que nous
poursuivons dans cette voie reste à
espérer que ce mécanisme permettra de
convaincre ceux qui pour qui pour leurs
propres raisons refuse encore d'être
vaccinés nous devons néanmoins garder à
l'esprit la nécessaire mesure que ce
type de dispositif retière après
quelques mois d'utilisation du passani
terre nous nous sommes accoutumés cela
suscite une première inquiétude observer
une banalisation conduisant à un usage
excessif je ne vous apprendrai rien une
mesure administrative
intervenant à matière de police générale
n'est légale que si l'atteinte portée au
libre exercice des droits et libertés de
chacun est adapté nécessaire et
proportionné ce principe s'impose à
l'administration et donc au gouvernement
mais cela doit aussi guidé le
législateur lorsqu'il fixe le cadre de
l'exercice de cette police
administrative cela nous impose de
respecter une proportion équilibrée
entre la gravité de l'atteinte portée
aux droits et libertés et l'intensité du
risque encouru en l'espèce sanitaires
c'est une exigence de l'état de droit
aussi nous devons tenir compte des
situations spécifiques et ne pas céder à
la facilité d'imposer des obligations
trop général seulement au motif qu'elles
sont commandes à appliquer dans ces
circonstances le texte adopté par
l'assemblée nationale nous paraissait
encore perfectible par exemple la
question de proportionnalité des mesures
se pose encore une fois à l'heure où les
gens jouent ont été rétablies dans le
nombre de lieux culturels
l'assemblée avait fait un pas vers plus
de flexibilité lors de l'examen du texte
en commission et nous regrettons qu'elle
soit revenue sur son intention en séance
publique pour y remédier un amendement
déposé au stade de la commission par
notre collègue nathalie delattre proposé
de réintégrer cette proportionnalité et
nous nous réjouissons que la commission
des lois est était du même avis en
adoptant un dispositif allant dans ce
sens dans l'ensemble les amendements
adoptés par la commission vente dans le
sens que nous attendions c'est à dire
d'assurer un meilleur encadrement
juridique du pass vaccinale de sorte
qu'il ne donne pas le sentiment d'être
un outil auquel tout gouvernement
pourrait recourir sans difficulté aussi
nous ne pouvons que nous réjouir de nos
premiers traits premiers travaux et
s'ils se poursuivre dans ce sens notre
groupe si montrera majoritairement
favorables à quelques exceptions près je
vous remercie
merci
de la parole à monsieur stéphane ravier
pour les sénateurs n'appartenant à aucun
groupe
je suis
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je ne m'adresserai pas
monsieur le ministre vu qu'il n'écoutait
aucun intervenant qui se succèdent à
cette tribune
est ce que le pass côte est ce que le
pass protège réellement la réponse est
non cette phrase n'est pas de moi mais
de jean françois delfraissy le président
du conseil scientifique quel aveu
le ministre l'objectif du ministre n'est
pas de soigner ni même de protéger les
français son objectif n'est plus
sanitaires il est politique il veut tout
simplement donner l'illusion de faire
quelque chose en prenant la décision la
plus arbitraire et autoritaire que ce
pays et tu à subir depuis trois quarts
de siècle si son objectif était de
protéger nos compatriotes il rendrait
les tests gratuits pour tous il
investirait massivement et depuis deux
ans dans l'hôpital et la recherche mais
rien rien de tout cela n'a été ne serait
ce qu'à mort c'est parce que tous
vaccinés que vous soyez mes chers
collègues je suis le seul le seul à
m'être fait tester ce matin et je suis
négatif je suis en mesure d'affirmer que
je ne le contaminerait personne ici qui
dans cet hémicycle peut en dire autant
la dérive autoritaire et terrifiante et
ce qui me terrifie encore plus la
docilité du parlement de l'assemblée
hier et du sénat aujourd'hui qui va
avaliser vos décisions sans que presque
personne n'y trouve rien à redire que
les élus que les députés de la
république en marche soit d'égoïsme des
godillots on le savait mais que la
majorité de droite du sénat voté ce
texte sans prendre en compte les
atteintes et irréparable commises sur
nos libertés
c'est plus qu'inquiétant c'est mortifère
oui vous êtes en train de martyriser la
démocratie en libye et la liberté ou
fait 2 5 millions de français dont je
suis des sous citoyens des non citoyens
qu'avons nous fait pour mériter un
pareil châtiment nous refusons de
prendre la dose d'un prétendu vaccin qui
est tellement efficace qu'il faut
l'administré tous les trois mois que le
masque est à nouveau obligatoire dans la
rue que des jauges sont instaurées dans
les théâtres et les stades que les
boîtes de nuit sont fermés bravo quelle
réussite nous n'en voulons pas
qu'importe le ministre nous l'imposent
de façon déguisée et alors même que le
conseil d'état s'y est opposé en ces
termes le pass sanitaire ne doit pas se
justifier par un objectif qui
consisterait à inciter les personnes
concernées à se faire vacciner c'est
pourtant clair et comme de l'état de
droit vous vous moquez vous devriez
aller encore plus loin il faudrait
écarter les non-vaccinés du reste de la
société les éloigner des vaccinés comme
gelée était sur le plateau de lci la
chaîne indigne pour masquer son
écrasante responsabilité dans le
développement de la pandémie en ayant
mis l'hôpital à loos
la stratégie du gouvernement repose sur
la division en désignant des boucs
émissaires conduisant à la mort telle
division des français sachons nous
rappeler de la citation de benjamin
franklin qui correspond parfaitement à
ce que nous sommes en train de vivre ce
qui ce qu'ils peuvent renoncer à la
liberté essentielle pour acheter un peu
de sécurité temporaire ne mérite ni la
liberté ni la sécurité alors mes chers
collègues en votant ce texte un fan vous
assassinez nos libertés sans assurer
notre sécurité ce texte est une honte
pour vous pour la république et surtout
surtout pour la france
la parole
l'un pris la parole
ah ah
la parole
un autre collègue jean-pierre sueur pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et vous
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers
collègues et cher rapporteur et rapporte
heureux et présidents et présidentes
notre position à nous a été clair
lorsque en novembre dernier à
l'instigation de notre collègue bernard
jomier que je tiens à saluer notre
groupe unanime a défendu ici
l'obligation vaccinale
pourquoi parce que nous croyons en la
science parce que nous sommes le pays de
pasteur parce que déjà dix vaccins sont
obligatoires dans ce pays nous avons
fait ce choix en toute responsabilité
nous le revendiquons et nous le
maintenons et nous étions seuls
le seul groupe à soutenir cela
et nous continuerons a présenté
l'amendement
qui conduira à l'obligation vaccinale
qui pour nous est la solution la plus
claire la plus nette la plus
compréhensible
et mes chers collègues
j'ai pris connaissance monsieur le
ministre
de ce que dit la drees vous savez que
l'adresse est un service de votre
ministère vous le connaissez très bien
et justement elle a dit ceci je cite
si on avait opté pour la vaccination
obligatoire des plus de 50 ans au lieu
du pass sanitaire en septembre 2021 on
aurait évité 45 % des entrées en
réanimation entre octobre et décembre
fin de citation
alors mes chers collègues
c'est important c'est d'important et
après un long débat très riche dans
notre groupe socialiste du sénat
nous avons considéré que dès lors que
nous étions pour l'obligation vaccinale
il était logique d'être pour le pass
vaccinale puisque cela se rapproche de
notre position mais nous persistons à
dire que vous devriez voter notre
amendement sur l'obligation vaccinale
car c'est parfaitement logique
toutefois nous serons extrêmement
vigilants mes chers collègues sur
plusieurs points qui justifie nos dix
neuf amendements et certains d'entre eux
particulièrement
premièrement pour ce qui est des
libertés publiques
et à cet égard je m'adresse à vous mes
collègues je m'adresse à notre
rapporteur philippe bas particulièrement
nous pensons qu'il doit être dit et
écrit clairement qu'il ne revient pas
aux responsables des établissements
recevant du public aux restaurateurs par
exemple de procéder à des contrôles
d'identité
il y a le pack sanitaires il y aura le
pass vaccinale une chose le contrôle
d'identité doit relever de la police de
la gendarmerie des personnes
assermentées mais il ne faut pas de
confusion et j'espère qu'au cours vu des
bâches m'adresse un autre rapporteur
philippe bas dont je salue le travail il
sera possible d'évoluer car je crois que
l'amendement que vous avez présenté
comprend un certain nombre de faiblesses
à cet égard
deuxièmement il nous paraît très
important nous allons le reprendre de
travailler aux dépistages dans les
écoles et collèges nous allons proposer
deux dépistages par semaine nous
maintenons cette position
et nous tenons à dire parce que nous
sommes au contact des populations dans
tous les départements de france que
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe dans
les écoles que c'est impossible d'avoir
un ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
changent de position tous les deux jours
tous les trois jours quand c'est pas
chaque jour si bien que cela crée une
confusion une exaspération chez les
enseignants chez les parents d'élèves et
il faut vraiment eu en finir avec cela
ce n'est pas possible monsieur le
ministre la santé de continuer comme ça
et je vous assure que quand je dis ça
nous sommes les représentants des
populations enfin je termine nous sommes
socialistes nous sommes très attachés à
la justice et à la justice dans le monde
entier en effet et nous nous battrons
toujours nous déposerons un amendement
sur la question des brevets et sur la
levée des brevets parce que dans cette
affaire il ya quand même des questions
d'argent et des questions de profits qui
sont considérables et que alors que
certains ont droit à la vaccination
les peuples le glissant dans la pauvreté
n'y ont pas droit
c'est une injustice nous devons lutter
pour l'égalité
à cet égard je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
ils ont donné la parole d'autres comme
aigle à florence lassarade pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avec 90 %
de français qui gît bhl vacciner même
partiellement je voulais d'abord
souligner qu'il ya un an personne
n'aurait eu espérer osé espérer un tel
succès le choix de la science le choix
de la responsabilité est toujours le bon
choix et c'est celui qui a été fait par
la grande majorité des français certes
la vaccination n'empêche pas totalement
d'être contaminés ou de transmettre le
virus mais elle réduit considérablement
le risque d'être hospitalisé admis en
réanimation et même de mourir du coc
vide ce bilan est déjà très positif même
si la vaccination nous a pas encore
permis de reprendre une vie normale nous
considérons qu'elle constitue l'un des
meilleurs outils pour lutter contre les
dangers de l'épidémie actuellement le
problème majeur c'est problème des
effectifs à l'hôpital et l'épuisement
des soignants la vague au micro onde
n'en finit pas de monter le taux de
positivité des tests a atteint des
niveaux jusqu'à présent inédit 20%
toutes les régions toutes les tranches
d'âge sont touchées par cette hausse la
pression sur l'hôpital s'accroît avec
une hausse régulière des
hospitalisations et l'incidence de l'aco
vide augmente chez les plus âgés ce qui
pourrait dans quelques semaines avoir un
impact important sur l'hôpital avec un
risque de saturation
comment allez-vous faire face au manque
de personnel au moment où le nombre
d'hospitalisations progresse
les conséquences sont déjà lourdes pour
les autres passions les déprogrammations
pourraient être évités si les lits de
réanimation n'étaient pas occupés par
des personnes non vaccinées
cette situation pose la question de la
responsabilité individuelle et de la
responsabilité collective par rapport à
la vaccination face à un virus qui
évolue constamment il est nécessaire
d'adapter des outils pour le combattre
mais il faut aussi anticiper
et là monsieur le ministre nous
regrettons le manque d'anticipation de
la part du gouvernement en effet les
personnes actuellement ranimation sont
majoritairement touchés par le ver lyon
delta qui n'est pas apparue ces jours-ci
seulement le texte aurait dû être
programmé à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée bien plus tôt et non pas au
moment où l'épidémie flanc le projet de
loi sur le pass vaccinale ne produira en
effet ses premiers effets qu'à partir là
de la fin du mois de février
nous sommes majoritairement favorable
vous l'avez compris à la vaccination au
pass vaccinale parce qu'il contribue à
augmenter la couverture vaccinale et que
la situation des hôpitaux nous le
commande
les services hospitaliers sont saturés
car cinq millions de français ont fait
le choix de ne pas se faire vacciner il
nous faut poursuivre nos efforts en
transformant le pass sanitaire en passe
vaccinale et en renforçant les mesures
de lutte contre la fraude nous
proposerons aussi un certain nombre de
mesures pour améliorer la protection de
tous les français face à l'épidémie
j'ai proposé notamment des amendements
pour maintenir et renforcer la
surveillance épidémiologique des eaux
usées et pour favoriser l'installation
des purificateurs d'air dans les
établissements d'enseignement
malheureusement ils ont été déclarés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 40
enfin concernant l'école
le gouvernement a fait le choix de
laisser le virus circule et on ne
repoussant pas à rentrer mais avec le
nouveau protocole la multiplication de
tests ni les parents ni les enfants ni
les enseignants ne savent plus comment
faire nous avons le sentiment que la
stratégie de lutte contre le coc vide et
j'irai sur le court terme et que les
décisions ne prennent pas la mesure des
difficultés de mise en oeuvre quotidien
pourquoi ne proposez vous plus de tests
salivaires dans les écoles pourquoi ne
propos vous et vous pas plus largement
les ffp2 sommes-nous encore en train de
gérer des pénuries enfin plutôt que
d'invectiver les non vaccinés
quelles mesures proposées vous pour
aller vers les plus vulnérables les plus
âgées les plus isolées et les plus
précaires nous attendons beaucoup des
débats qui vont suivre pour améliorer la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
merci ma chère collègue
donner la parole maintenant notre
collègue bernard jeault billet pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mesdames et messieurs pris dans les
rapporteurs merci chers collègues ce
texte au fond nous pose un problème de
naissance il est mal née il est mal née
et j'en veux pour preuve la façon dont
s'est déroulé le débat à l'assemblée
nationale
ce n'est pas un texte de réponse à la
vague actuelle notre à porter a raison
sur ce point le rat comme sur d'autres
d'ailleurs
et pourtant le gouvernement a tenté de
passer en force jusqu à s'offusquer que
les députés ne veuille pas délibéré à 4
heures du matin
et bien c'est compliqué politiquement
et pourtant vous savez que nous ne
sommes pas irresponsables en termes de
gestion de la crise sanitaire
d'approuver un texte qui à ce point est
une posture politique
il y avait la possibilité
monsieur le ministre de revenir devant
le parlement comme nous vous l'avions
proposé en janvier février pour faire un
point sur la situation vous ne vouliez
pas
à la fin de l'année dernière constatant
que l'épidémie devenait hors de contrôle
et que dans les écoles notamment vous
avez délibérément laissé circuler le
virus nous ne cesserons de rappeler que
le ministre de l'éducation a allégé le
protocole quand le nombre de classes
fermées augmenter et bien la situation à
échapper totalement avec le variant au
micro au certes il aurait circulé
personne aucun pays n'échappera vario
micro limpide d'une telle intensité nous
pouvions y échapper
alors vous venez avec ce texte qui a un
autre défaut c'est que certes il faut
s'adapter mais il faut aussi que la loi
elle se projette dans la durée et
légiférer dans la durée c'est dire à nos
compatriotes que certes peut-être le
scénario optimisme seul ministre mais
qu' il faudrait mieux prévoir le
maintien d'une protection collective
élevé dans la durée pour notre
population et pour ça nous nous vous
proposons une méthode l'adoption d'un
principe sans le déguiser l'obligation
vaccinale universel parce que ça
rassemble parce que ça ne clique pas les
français entre eux parce qu'on ne dit
pas que telle profession doit les
gendarmes est à l'autre ne doit pas les
policiers parce que nous signifions
ainsi et c'est le rôle de la politique
que tous ensemble nous faisons face à
cette épidémie que nous devons tous la
protection aux soignants de notre pays à
notre système de santé et les uns aux
autres et puis après on voit les
modalités d'application et on ne posera
pas convaincre et contraindre c'est un
piège oui il ya une part de contraintes
et le pass vaccinale ou le certificat de
vaccination on l'appellera comme on veut
peut-être un des outils de contrôle nous
ne l'excluons pas nous en discuterons
les modalités mais dans un cadre bien
posé bien née et puis à le convaincre
bien sûr que personne auxquelles
personne ne veut renoncer et ceux qui
répètent que on ne mène pas assez ce
travail d'aller vers ont également
raison et bien si ce cadre était ainsi
posée nous pourrions débattre et
légiférer sereinement et non pas pour
les quinze jours à venir et encore une
fois sans efficience mais de façon
beaucoup plus durable alors voilà notre
position elle est simple elle est claire
elle a toujours été la même c'est dans
ce cadre que nous étudierons ce texte
que nous tenterons d'y apporter comme
l'a dit mon collègue jean pierre sueur
les améliorations qui sont
indispensables pour qu'on puisse le
voter etc ainsi nous respecterons les
français journée
la parole est bon pour notre collègue
muriel jourda
[Applaudissements]
ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il m'appartient nous
faire valoir la position des sénateurs
du groupe l'est républicain qui malgré
les efforts pas tant de nos deux
rapporteurs ne partage pas l'opinion
majoritaire et ne voterons pas ce pass
vaccinale
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
beaucoup de choses resteraient à dire
sur par exemple la façon dont ont été
caricaturé ceux qui étaient opposés à la
position du gouvernement parfois par des
propos qu'ils tiennent plus des pires
travers des réseaux sociaux que d'une
méthode digne de gouvernement beaucoup
de choses resteraient à dire aussi sur
la gestion parfois trop sanitaire de
cette crise qui a occulté les autres
enjeux et qui a même été jusqu'à
occulter que la santé ça ne se résume
pas à attraper ou à ne pas attraper le
virus du coc vide par l'anp ont
d'ailleurs au pédopsychiatre
beaucoup de choses aussi resterait à
dire sur les tranches philosophie de
société qui nous pousse à faire courir
tous les risques d'un vaccin somme toute
assez récent à nos enfants plutôt que de
convaincre les plus âgés d'aller se
faire vacciner
mais le temps est compté et je voudrais
aussi parlé de nos concitoyens qui sont
opposés à ce passe vaccinale
ceux que j'ai rencontrés ne sont pas des
irresponsables
ce ne sont pas des égoïstes ils ne sont
pas contre la science ils ne sont
parfois même pas pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux contre le gouvernement je
crois qu'il faut se rappeler que ce sont
les mêmes français si lorsque latin de
la plus importante aux libertés a été
portée au cours de la gestion de cette
pandémie c'est à dire le confinement se
sont pliés à cette décision ils s'y sont
pliés parce qu'ils l'ont comprise nous
ne connaissions pas ce virus nous ne
disposons pas de moyens préventifs nous
ne disposions pas de moyens curatifs
et la solution du confinement semblait
être la moins mauvaise des solutions
aujourd'hui s'ils sont opposés à ce
passe vaccinale c'est parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas la décision qui est
prise il ne la comprennent pas pas
seulement parce que le président de la
république indiqué nous n'arriverions
jamais à se passe vaccinale après tout
il serait malhonnête de prétendre qu'il
est simple de gérer cette pandémie et il
faut pouvoir changer d'opinion lorsque
les chais est la réalité objective nous
amènent à changer d'opinion mais en
réalité quelle est la réalité
aujourd'hui qui nous emmènerait a changé
d'opinion chacun a dit ici je crois que
tout le monde en est convaincu ce vaccin
n'est que peu efficace et il ne permet
pas en tout cas d'atteindre l'immunité
collective plus nous sommes vaccinés
plus nous sommes contaminé c'est une
évidence sur laquelle personne ne revit
en revanche et ça n'est pas un petit
apport il permet de limiter les formes
graves de ce box de ce virus or nous
savons qui est porteur de ses formes
graves nous le savons parce que nous
avons désormais deux ans d'ancienneté ce
sont les personnes les plus fragiles
soit par leur âge soit par leur état de
santé soit en raison des deux et ce sont
ces personnes dont on nous dit qu'elles
sont le plus majoritairement dans les
services de soins critiques qui sont
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté
par parenthèse je dirais qu'un un
système de santé d'un pays de 2 67
millions d'habitants qui n'arrive pas à
supporter un peu moins de 4000 personnes
en soins critiques pose la question de
savoir si ce n'est pas moi le virus que
le système de santé qui est en
difficulté et qui pose des problèmes
[Applaudissements]
ce sont ses concitoyens ceux qui sont le
plus à risque de faire des formes graves
qu'il faut aller chercher me semble-t-il
or nous sommes dans un pays où le taux
de vaccination des personnes âgées n'est
pas maximale il faut le savoir que sur
une certaine tranche d'âge et bien les
18 24 ans sont mieux vacciner que les
personnes âgées etc cette politique que
nous aurions voulu voir porter
pouvoir vacciner ceux qui peuvent le
mieux bénéficié des effets du vaccin et
non pas une population tout entière et à
quel prix car c'est me semble-t-il le
second écueil de ce texte qui consiste à
attaquer frontalement l'état de droit
l'état de droit
c'est la fin de l'arbitraire
or aujourd'hui on vous propose de punir
des personnes parce qu'elles ne se
vaccinent pas alors même qu'il n'ya
aucune obligation vaccinale et ça c'est
tout à fait arbitraire quel que soit ce
que souhaitent nos dirigeants quels que
soient leurs envies nous ne pouvons être
soumise à ses envies voilà pourquoi mes
chers collègues à certains d'entre nous
est un certain nombre de français sont
opposés à ce passe vaccinale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs quelques
éléments de réponse
d'abord sur la politique de test il a
été un petit peu question pas beaucoup
eu deux interventions qui ont fait
allusion dire que nous répondons à toute
la demande de tests dans notre pays et
d'ailleurs on peut le reconnaître et
s'en satisfaire il ya 12 millions de
français qu'on souhaitait être testé la
semaine dernière ou qui ont eu besoin
d'être testé ils ont tous pu être testés
alors il ya évidemment ça crée parfois
des files d'attentes dans votre
pharmacie j'en ai pleinement conscience
je remercie d'ailleurs les pharmaciens
pour leur mobilisation extraordinaire
parce qu'ils ont permis de tenir cette
montée en charge des dispositifs de
dépistage mais à l'inversé messieurs les
sénateurs si j'entends ce que c'est
parce que vous avez dit mais j'entends
remonter dans l'opinion un débat est-ce
qu'on ne resterait pas trop en france
est ce qu'on ne devrait pas se limiter à
tester que certaines catégories de
population j'ai l'impression d'un d'un
retour en arrière deux en avant deux en
arrière puisqu'il ya deux ans justement
nous disions nous ne testons que les cas
graves les cas douteux les cas
spécifiques et nous sommes dans un
diagnostic
nous sommes sinon d'un système de
diagnostic clinique comme nous le
faisons habituellement avec la grippe
jeu dans le débat qui commence à monter
sur faisait en outre test c'est une
demande de revenir en arrière deux en
deux ans en arrière alors même qu'on
nous demandait qu'il fallait tester tout
le monde et moi je crois que les
français quand ils ont un doute sur leur
diagnostic
ils doivent pouvoir une réponse en bonne
et due forme savoir s'ils sont ou non
porter du coc vide il faut pas casser le
thermomètre est donc le système tient
sur la question des du pass des enfants
juste vous redire sur les fins des
enfants sur les 12 17 ans qu'il ya eu je
le dis ça veut pas dire qu'il doit se
reproduire ici mais à l'assemblée
nationale il beaucoup de débats et vous
en aurez ici aussi sur la question du
pass des ados est ce qu'on doit
appliquer le pass vaccinale aux ados et
la disposition qui consiste à ne pas
l'appliquer pour les activités sportives
culturelles péri et extrascolaires a
recueilli quand même je le souligne
parce que c'est la première fois en
douze textes que ça m'arrive l'unanimité
des trois cent soixante députés présents
- 2 voies
il a été trouvé cet équilibre
considérant que le pass vaccinale pour
les bars et les restaurants pour les
pour les adolescents se justifier
d'autant que la plupart des adolescents
qui ne sont pas vaccinés ont pour
parents des adultes qui ne sont pas
vaccinés et donc ils ne peuvent pas de
fait les emmener dans les bars et les
restaurants mais vous aurez l'occasion
d'en débattre sur le fait de fixer un
seuil de péremption pour le pass
vaccinale dans la loi j'entends
parfaitement la logique est d'ailleurs
passé le rapporteur c'est c'est quelque
chose de cohérent quand on y réfléchit
de se dire en fait est ce qu'il ya un
niveau de charge sanitaire ou
épidémiques en dessous duquel on n'a
plus besoin de ces outils le mettre dans
la loi me pose des difficultés majeures
parce que nous sommes face à des
situations qui nous montre vague après
vague qu'elles sont imprévisibles
personne n'aurait pu si nous avions du
riz envisager un seuil par exemple de
nombre de contaminations dans notre pays
déclencheur des mesures sanitaires qui
aurait pu prédire qu'un jour nous
aurions 350000 contamination 24 heures
donc le seuil surtout dans la loi est
rigide et nous empêchent d'agir en
revanche les dispositions actuelles en
matière d'application du pass vaccinale
renvoie à la notion d'urgence sanitaire
ne sont légitimes et que pour des motifs
sanitaires et s'il s'avérait que la
situation épidémique et sanitaire
n'était plus jugé compatible avec le
maintien du pass la justice la justice
ordonnerait à ce que ces dispositifs
tombe donc il est déjà prévu par le mode
parle je parle la loi qui a été adoptée
cette espèce de garde-fous qui fait qu'à
tout moment quelqu'un peut considérer
est saisie réussissent pour dire je
pense que cet outil n'est plus justifiée
au regard de la situation sanitaire est
alors nous ne pouvons plus utiliser
sur le
sur les dispositifs de repentir
j'entends aussi le débat et qui est tout
à fait légitime sur faut-il mettre dans
la loi faut-il passer par une une
circulaire de police les circulaires
pénale
le message qu'on veut envoyer aux
français c'est le message que vous me
demander d'envoyer vous me dites faut
convaincre les réticents faut convaincre
les réticents alors oui on fait du aller
vers oui les médecins les pharmaciens
des infirmiers à domicile et s'acheva
blé qui n'est les étudiants tout le
monde dans les centres au domicile les
collectivités territoriales bien sûr je
vais pas les oublier ici au sénat les
associations sont mobilisées pour aller
chercher les personnes quittant pas
vacciner mais il ya aussi des gens qui
ne sont pas vaccinés qu'il regrette et
qui ont disposé d'un faux parce qu'à un
moment donné faux certificats ou faux
parce qu'ils se sont dit j'aurais jamais
besoin d'être vaccinés
ces personnes a aujourd'hui il y en a
qui se présentent en centre et quand
elles arrivent ensemble on leur dit mais
non vous avez déjà eu vent de dos non
non c'est pas vrai enfin j'ai pas aimé
dose on m'a bidouiller un truc j'ai payé
s'emballe mais en fait maintenant je me
rends compte qu'en fait ça ça arrive et
ça arrive ça arrive ce que nous voulons
c'est envoyer le message à ces personnes
que faites vous vacciner c'est
l'essentiel on efface l'ardoisé qui veut
pas dire que si vous qu'on attrape
quelqu'un qui à défaut passe ou des
auteurs de faux passe ils sont exemptés
de rendre des comptes devant la justice
et pour ces personnes là parce qu'on est
dans cette démarche jusqu'au boutiste on
a proposé ce dispositif travailler avec
les parlementaires à l'assemblée
nationale sur la question des écoles je
ne dis rien pas même si j'ai eu des
interventions pour redire encore une
fois le virus peut circuler dans les
écoles il peut circuler dans tous les
milieux les enfants peuvent se
contaminaient est d'ailleurs le taux
d'incidence sur les enfants aient été
levés il ya très peu de formes graves
chez les enfants et heureusement mais ça
peut arriver mais c'est très rare les
enfants peuvent transmettre le virus
bien malgré eux évidemment à des adultes
et dans votre entourage vous avez
sûrement des gens qui dit j'ai été
contaminé mon fils avait été contaminée
à l'école etc donc on est obligé de
continuer d'avoir suivi épidémique et a
suivi épidémiologique chez les enfants
on a un dispositif qui fonctionne en
dispositifs de droit commun on ne lance
pas des opérations de test dans toutes
les classes dans toutes les écoles etc
il faudrait des bras dans des
proportions absolument dithyrambiques or
vous savez on vaccine beaucoup et on
teste beaucoup par ailleurs et donc il a
été demandé d'avoir trois test un test
initialement antigénique ou pcr à j0 et
ensuite de tests deux auto test à la
maison sachant que l'auto tess est en
train de rentrer dans la pratique et
dans la routine je dirais d'un certain
nombre de familles françaises voyant que
dans cette période d'épidémie
galopante tout le monde était saturé les
pharmacies les laboratoires y tiennent
face à la demande je le redis 12
millions de tests c'est un exploit quand
on avait fait des prévisions au
ministère sur combien on arrivera à
monthey ont plafonné à 7 8 millions ils
sont en train de nous montrer qu'on
avait tort donc je remercie encore une
fois les acteurs et notamment les
pharmaciens ce que sont donné un gros
coup de boost la semaine dernière bref
il ya des files d'attentes on n'a pas
envie que les parents attendent avec les
enfants devant les pharmacies ou dans
les laboratoires pendant deux heures et
qu'ils ne puissent pas aller travailler
qui se retrouvent pénalisés avec
pragmatisme on dit maintenant on a
l'expérience de l'auto test on sait que
ça peut fonctionner on bascule en auto
test et voilà donc c'est je bois je
préfère
ils fois qu'on soit capable de se dire
on adapte notre dispositif pour tenir
compte de la réalité telle que vécue par
les français plutôt que de nous endetter
avec est quelque chose qui poserait plus
de difficultés dernier point
est tout à l'heure en donnant à
déchiffrer ses draps je suis toujours
très attention parce que comme les
vidéos sénat parfois font foi je je
oui monsieur hervé c'est normal c'est
juste moi même